foreign
is one of our favorite Disney Princesses
but do you really know what happened to
her make sure you watch this video Until
the End to know what Polynesian people
think about this movie if you love Moana
as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
the disturbing real story behind Moana
who is Maui while Moana isn't part of
the Polynesian mythology the Disney
movie was actually inspired by another
character Maui we can find this demigod
in many cultures but the creators
decided to focus more on the Polynesian
mythology however when they first looked
at him many people didn't recognize him
that's because Maui was supposed to be a
slim young man coming of age with a top
knot on his head we don't know what
Disney did to him but he ended up being
huge and covered with tattoos with long
flowing hair on his shoulders actually
the animator's first wanted Maui to be
much thinner and bald but they chose to
change his physical appearance to make
him look more heroic many people were
upset with that choice but we'll talk
about this later Maui's family looks
really different too in mythology Maui
actually had four brothers he was also
the son of a God and Immortal woman
making him a demigod unlike what we see
in the movie where he was abandoned by
his parents and raised by a God but just
because he was a demigod doesn't mean
that he was all good actually the
original story involved much violent
stuff and things that should have only
been seen by adults this is why it was
left out of the film that was meant to
be seen by children but there are
actually some things that Maui we can be
proud of what really happened what did
Maui do to be so popular in many
cultures the best known myth was that
the demigod was the one who created the
islands it all started when Maui
convinced his brothers to go on a
fishing trip but the demigod caught his
magical fishing hook on the ocean floor
this was when he told his brothers that
they should paddle as hard as they could
because they had caught a big fish they
paddled so hard that they shored up
several islands that would later make up
the islands of Hawaii and many other
Islands in another version of the story
he actually caught a huge fish but his
brothers opened it without his
permission and it broke up into
mountains Cliffs and valleys the legend
says that if they had waited to open it
the islands would have been plain flat
one of his biggest accomplishments was
also restraining the sun when he lassoed
it with his sister's hair he wouldn't
let it go until the sun agreed to give
them long days in the summer and short
days in the winter in the Hawaiian
culture Maui is also responsible for
passing the secret of fire to humans we
actually hear about many of these
stories in the song you're welcome but
but it was really easy to miss if you
didn't know anything about the
Polynesian culture but no matter what
there are some things that Disney got
right in this movie what is Right Disney
has often been accused of being
insensitive with cultures mostly when
they turned Pocahontas's tragic story
into a fairy tale but this time the
creators wanted to make people proud
they have been interested in the demigod
Maui but Disney Animation Chief told
them to go research before doing
anything this is why the creators went
to Polynesia many times to meet a group
of anthropologists cultural
practitioners historians linguists and
choreographers these people helped them
make sure that the story was accurate
this is why they deleted a scene where
Moana threw a temper tantrum and hurled
coconuts down on the sand because it was
considered to be extremely offensive
they are also the ones who said that
Maui couldn't be bald because that's
where the power of the demigod came from
during their first trip the creators
also saw that Polynesian women were so
beautiful that they should make the
story about one of them this is how
Moana was created Disney also cast
Hawaiian voice actors who were
encouraged to rewrite the lines to add
more accurate Hawaiian slang this is how
there are some things that they actually
got right people love to see that Moana
was a strong Disney princess who didn't
need a prince they took the time to show
some Polynesian traditions and they made
sure that the community was the most
important part of the story but can we
really forgive them after all the things
they did wrong what is wrong when people
learned that Disney was making a movie
about a princess from a different origin
many people were getting ready to be
offended and one of the first things
that shocked them was how Maui looked as
we have said before the demigod was
supposed to be a teenager on the verge
of manhood but he was Illustrated as a
kind of buffoon and some people thought
that he looked kind of stupid others
were also offended by his size as they
said it perpetuated offensive images of
Polynesians as overweight some people
didn't even want their kids to watch the
movie because of that it just got worse
when Disney created a costume of Maui
featuring a tattooed body stalking it is
not a surprise that this Brown face
caused a big controversy people also
didn't like how coconuts were used as a
caricature of Pacific people it just got
worse when they depicted a whole race of
people the kakamora as evil coconuts but
the problem is that according to the
legend they were simply short-statured
people of the Solomon Islands Disney had
no right to portray them like that and
let's not forget that coconut can also
be a racial slur against people from the
Pacific Islands and these are only some
of the things that offended them what
Polynesian people think
but what do Polynesian people have to
say about this will Varner from BuzzFeed
ask some of his friends to talk about
Moana when the movie came out some of
them were excited to see people like
them on the big screen While others were
getting ready to be offended but they
did love a lot of things about the movie
like the grandma the raw color and
beauty of the islands the songs and the
community they also all agreed that
their favorite character was Moana
however there are still some things that
they didn't like it is not a surprise
that many of them didn't like how Maui
looked one of them also noted that women
couldn't become Chief in the Tongan
culture surprisingly many of them didn't
like the giant crab and one also said
that coconuts just aren't scary but no
matter what if they could change one
thing that would probably be some voice
actors or the sound of the choir oh and
one of them couldn't handle the chicken
and another still argued that women
can't become Chief but overall they had
to admit that it wasn't that bad what do
you think about Moana do you think that
Disney did a good job or they should
have stuck to the real story don't be
shy to answer in the comments section
down below we all love watching Disney
movies no matter how old we are but if
you ever read the original tells you'll
find out that they are absolutely not
appropriate for kids that's because
we're not sure whether they are reading
a love story or a horror story stay
tuned until the end to know what really
happened to Rapunzel if you love Disney
as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 disturbing real stories behind Disney
fairy tales Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs we all remember the story of Snow
White the young girl who ran away from
her home because her stepmother was
jealous of her beauty she wanted the
hunter to come back with her heart but
the princess had the chance to stay with
the Seven Dwarfs it didn't keep the evil
queen from trying to get rid of her one
more time and make her eat a poisoned
Apple when we think about it the Disney
movie really sounds like a horror story
too but the original story is actually
worse in The Brothers Grimm version the
evil queen still wanted to get rid of
her daughter but this time she wanted
the hunter to come back with her lungs
and her liver when he came back with the
body parts of a boar the queen
immediately ate them thinking they
belonged to Snow White but when she
heard the truth she tried to get rid of
the princess two other times before
giving her the poisoned Apple the evil
queen sold her bodice laces that were so
tight that she stopped breathing and
also gave her a poisoned comb it was a
warning to teach young girls that they
shouldn't become vain at the end of the
tale the evil queen was punished when
she was forced to wear a burning hot
iron Shoes and Dance until she takes her
last breath surprisingly as grown-ups we
prefer this ending hey guys we are so
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup hacks and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it and be sure
to let us know what you think in the
comment section we'd love to hear from
you see you there Cinderella in this
story a young girl is forced to work as
a servant before her fairy godmother
gives her the chance to go to the ball
where she meets her prince charming it
looks really romantic except when you
think that he didn't even recognize the
love of his life after that night but
you will find out that it's not that bad
when you hear what really happened to
Cinderella and her sisters in the
brother's Grim version the princess
didn't have a fairy godmother but
planted a tree by her mother's grave and
prayed under it every day this is where
she found dresses to wear to each ball
as she went to three balls in this story
The Prince only danced with her before
the mysterious princess disappeared by
jumping into a pigeon coop or climbing
up a pear tree this is why on the third
night he decided to set a trap to make
sure that she wouldn't escape the
stairway was smeared with pitch and this
is why she lost a shoe when he tried to
find who it belonged to this is when
things go a little crazy the sisters
tried it and cut off their toes and
their heels to fit in the shoes but the
prince noticed the blood when Cinderella
finally got married they tried to attend
the wedding but their eyes were packed
out by birds this is not what we call a
happily ever after Sleeping Beauty this
story was already weird to start with a
young woman falls asleep until she is
saved by the kiss of a prince but when
you think about it it is not romantic at
all to kiss someone without their
consent but it is not that bad when you
hear about the original story in the
original tale by John Batista Basile
called the Sun the Moon and Talia
absolutely nothing can ever be
considered romantic this time there are
no fairies but men who foretell that the
princess will be put in great danger by
a splinter of flax the king tried to
protect her but on her 16th birthday she
saw an Old Woman spinning on a spindle
when she tried to stretch the flax it
went under her nail and she passed away
when her father found out about this he
let the body of his daughter in his home
and left this place forever after some
time another king came to their home and
his Falcon flew into the window of his
Palace he entered the place and found a
beautiful girl who couldn't wake up this
is when things get really inappropriate
he took her to bed and made love to her
let's just tell you once again that dead
girls can't consent Talia became
pregnant and gave birth to twins and
it's when his son sucked on her finger
and removed the Splinter of flax that
she finally woke up that's not romantic
The Little Mermaid this Disney movie
looks really nice before you think that
Ariel gave away everything for a
stranger and changed who she was to
please him everything was fine at the
end but we still think that she took too
many risks for a man that she didn't
know unfortunately for the original
Little Mermaid things didn't work out
for her in Anderson's Tale the story is
really similar but the choice that she
makes is worse The Little Mermaid
exchanges her tongue for a pair of legs
but this time if she fails she won't
only turn back into a mermaid she will
actually die if she fails just to make
things worse she wants to walk on earth
because humans have eternal Souls while
mermaids don't it just makes her death
much more terrifying and having legs is
not as good as you think in the original
story every single step she takes will
feel like she is walking on Sharp shards
of glass in the original Tale the prince
ends up marrying the woman he thinks is
the person who saved him the Mermaid has
one more chance to stay alive if she
gets rid of the prince but she fails
instead she throws herself into the sea
and turns into seafoam if there is one
thing that can make her happier it's
that she could earn a soul after 300
years for the good thing that she did is
this really a happy ending Beauty and
the Beast this love story was just
terrible when you think about it when
someone forces you to stay in their
Castle no matter how nice they try to be
you shouldn't marry them we know that
the Beast became a better man but things
like that don't happen in real life you
don't change people people change
themselves this time the original story
from Jean-Marie Le Prince de Beaumont is
not so far from what we saw in the two
Disney movies The Young woman was named
beauty which is actually the meaning of
Belle in French her father used to be a
rich Merchant but things didn't really
work out for him and he became poor
beauty also had many siblings including
two evil sisters once again his father
ended up being the prisoner of the Beast
because he stole a rose the Beast told
him that he would let him go in exchange
for one of his daughters and he accepted
in exchange for things to give to his
family you know the rest of the story
but what is disturbing is that when
Beauty came back home her sisters were
extremely jealous of her luxurious life
this is why her sisters forced her to
stay even though she promised the Beast
that she would come back because they
wanted the monster to eat her alive
after all she is better with the Beast
than with her family Aladdin this time
we have nothing against the main
character even though Aladdin was a
thief he had a heart of gold but we can
say the same thing about Jafar who was
trying to force Jasmine to marry him
which is not really a thing that kids
should see this time the original story
is really similar there is one thing
that really surprised Us Aladdin used to
live in China which makes him Chinese
and not Arab we don't know why they
changed this important detail but we
have to admit we'd love seeing the
beauty of this country once again the
thief was recruited by a sorcerer to
Spill the magic lamp but this time he
pretended to be the little brother of
Aladdin's late father when he got the
lamb Aladdin even wanted to sell it in
exchange for food until he met the genie
this time it was much easier to marry
the princess as he had just become rich
and Powerful to let the Sultan's
daughter fall into his arms what is fun
about this is that she used to be called
Princess bad rubidor so we totally
understand why they changed her name to
Jasmine the ending is more violent as
Aladdin gets rid of the Sorcerer And
then slays his brother disguised as a
woman but at the end the couple lives
happily ever after so we could say that
it's our favorite story for now
Pocahontas you probably already know
that Pocahontas really existed but if
you were thinking about a young princess
who fell in love with John Smith and
saved his life before he has to come
back to Europe that's because Disney has
been lying to you this story is
absolutely wrong first Pocahontas was
only a nickname meaning spoiled child
and the girl's real name was matoka she
was actually still a kid when she met
John Smith so they were not in love with
each other even though Sparks didn't fly
between them the man claimed that the
young Native American did save his life
when he was captured by powhatan's men
but nothing proves that it really
happened as Smith only talked about this
years later Matoaca was also in contact
with the Europeans as an important
supplier of food and an Informer for the
colony however they didn't like her in
the best way because she was taken
prisoner at age 17 and they held her
hostage for more than a year she made a
deal with another man John Rolfe who
promised that she would be released if
she married him matoika became Rebecca
roll had a son named Thomas and was
forced to move to Europe she passed away
really young at age 21. whoever says
that this is a love story is absolutely
wrong and Disney made a mistake when
they decided to change change her story
Mulan here's a woman that should be a
role model this time Mulan didn't want
to be a housewife and decided to become
a warrior instead even if it meant that
she had to risk her life and pretend
that she was a man she did face danger
but at least this time Disney didn't
want us to believe that it was romantic
but did you know that the movie was
actually inspired by a legendary Warrior
you can read the original story of the
Chinese tell the ballad of Mulan then a
play was produced to show what happened
to Hua Milan some people think that this
amazing woman really existed and this is
her story we'll tell you about the main
differences when we compare the tale to
the movie Mulan was actually a really
skilled Warrior and didn't have to train
like the young woman that we saw in the
movie she grew up as a tomboy and her
father taught her how to fight at a
young age Mulan didn't have to lie to
her parents about wanting to go to war
and they even supported her because it
was the most natural decision for her
she was also super confident from the
start and obviously didn't have any
sidekick we also love that there was no
big gender reveal she just decided to
share her secret and everyone was okay
with that why can't we see a movie about
the real Milan The Princess and the Frog
this one is a classic but it still took
years before we had the chance to see
the movie and Disney really surprised us
we all thought it was weird to kiss a
frog and we're happy to see that Tiana
thought the same thing too but what
really happened in the original Tale the
young woman was not a waitress but a
real princess the most beautiful one
anyone has ever seen she liked to go
into the forest and sit on the edge of a
cool well to play with a golden ball she
dropped it in the water and a Frog
offered to give it back to her as long
as she would accept him as her companion
and Playmate she said yes but broke her
promise when she came back home without
him the next day the Frog was at her
door she had to spend some time with him
even if she was disgusted by the little
creature the princess became angry and
threw him against the wall this was when
the Frog turned into a beautiful prince
who is now her companion surprisingly he
forgave her and they came back to his
kingdom to together so the girl was
actually really mean in the original
tale and there was no kiss so we
absolutely don't understand where it
comes from for once we think that Disney
really did a better job Tangled this was
one of the most recent Disney movies
based on a tale that people had the
chance to read years ago Flynn Rider is
clearly one of the most Charming princes
but isn't it weird to think that he
entered her room without her permission
and the princess decided to leave with
him anyway it was the best decision she
ever made but it's still weird anyway
the original tell comes from the
brothers Grim the beginning of the story
is really similar but this time the man
that saved her was actually a prince he
was seduced by her voice and wanted to
meet her he asked Rapunzel to let down
her hair and climbed he was so nice that
she quickly fell in love with him and
they got engaged on the same night she
asked him to bring a strand of silk
every time he would come to visit her so
she could weave a ladder but the
Sorceress found out about it caught her
hair and let Rapunzel suffer in the
wilderness she tricked the prince he
himself out of the Tower and poked out
his eyes blind he finally heard
Rapunzel's voice in the forest after she
had given birth to twins she saved him
with her tears and they lived happily
ever after in his kingdom which is your
favorite original fairy tale don't be
shy to answer in the comment section
down below we love hearing what you
think you have probably already watched
the Disney movie Mulan but even though
we'll probably never know if this woman
really existed we know that her story
has been told during the Wei Dynasty
from 386 to 557 A.D there are many
different versions of this town and this
is why we are going to tell you all
about them make sure you watch the whole
video to know how the story ended if you
love Mulan as much as we do don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
the messed up origins of Mulan the
beginning her story has been told for
centuries and this is what makes Mulan
one of the most legendary women of
ancient China but how did it all start
you probably probably remember the
Disney movie in which mulan's family
expected her to become a good housewife
for her future husband unfortunately she
didn't pass the test with the Matchmaker
and everyone was disappointed this was
when she realized that she had better
things to do but in the original ballad
Mulan was simply washing clothes when
she heard that the Army was recruiting
new soldiers one man from every family
her father was too old to survive the
war so she decided to take his place in
another version of the tale she saw on
posters that the Khan was calling troops
and she saw her father's name on the
list as he didn't have any grown-up Sons
she wanted to serve in the Army in her
father's place no matter what in both
cases her family knew that she was
planning to do this and then had nothing
against this idea there was nothing
wrong with a young woman going to war
and they probably already knew that this
is where she belonged the war in the
Disney movie Mulan was not better than
anyone else when she decided to go to
war she was really unskilled with
weapons and had to learn how to be a man
but she had more ambition than any other
and this is when she trained harder to
achieve her goals but in the original
Tale the young woman really knew what
she was doing and one version of the
tale her father thought that women
should know how to fight too and this is
why she was said to have practice with
different weapons the war hero was known
for practicing martial arts such as Kung
Fu and was also skilled with a sword in
another tale she even had the chance to
go to war with a sword inherited from
the ancestors of the family in another
version of The Ballad of Mulan she
simply bought a horse a saddle a bridle
and a long whip and decided to leave her
family for a couple of years oh and as
you can guess there was no small dragon
or funny cricket to help her in the
original story but you'll have to stay
tuned to know for how many years she was
part of the army and what happened at
the end the love story if you watch the
Disney movie based on Mulan you probably
know that she fell in love with the Army
Captain Felicia in the second movie they
got married and were directed by the
emperor to escort his three daughters to
a neighboring Kingdom where they could
get married but was this actually part
of the original tale it's an only one
version of the story that we can hear
about him it is believed that during the
war Mulan met an officer named Jin Yang
and fell in love with him however things
were a little complicated as everyone
believed that she was a man and young
was only interested in marrying a woman
but after a couple of years on the
battlefield Mulan was promoted to
General and people learned that she was
actually a woman we'll talk about that
gender reveal shortly after this was
when young became more attached to her
they both started dreaming about getting
married to each other however we don't
know if they ever tied the knot and any
of these stories we have to admit that
we think that mulan's story is even
better when she doesn't need a man we
prefer the version where she has no one
in her heart and no one in her mind but
would be ready to do anything for only
one man her father you don't need
difference to be a Disney princess the
gender reveal in the Disney movie
pretending to be a man to join the Army
was punishable by death however Shang
spared her life and she was expelled
from the Army until she found another
way to help them but how did people
react to this gender reveal in the
original Tale in the Love Story Jin Yang
quickly found out that Mulan was a woman
and simply became more attached to her
and dreamed about marrying her this is
why we can guess that her gender was not
a problem for him but other soldiers
also started to find out that Mulan was
actually a woman this was why one day
before a typical battle their General
decided to go onto the battlefield in
women's clothes she didn't want to hide
her true identity anymore the soldiers
were not shocked actually they really
respected and admired her for her
bravery they couldn't believe that one
of the best members of the army was
actually a woman and this is what
inspired them to win another battle in
other versions of this tale Mulan simply
wore her old-time clothes when she came
back home and her soldiers were inspired
to find out that she was a woman we
think that the Disney movie would have
been more inspiring if soldiers didn't
care about mulan's gender but only cared
about how good she was the ending in the
Disney movie Mulan was praised by the
emperor and the inhabitants of the city
after saving China she then declined his
offer to become his advisor and asked to
return to her family to present the
gifts to her father most of the original
Tales are similar but some of them are
more tragic than others in The Ballad of
Mulan the war hero actually fought for
12 years in the Army and even became a
general she was offered many gifts but
the only thing she wanted was a horse
she took off her wartime gown and put on
her old-time clothes this is when some
soldiers came to see her and realized
that she was actually a woman but in
another version of this tale Mulan
returned home only to find out that her
father had passed away she didn't feel
like a hero but only thought that she
lost the love of her life and was
haunted by her experiences on the
battlefield this is how her life ended
tragically so which tale do you prefer
the Disney movie or the original story
we all know and love the Disney classic
Pocahontas but the truth behind the
story is actually a lot more messed up
than anyone ever thought stay tuned to
find out why John Smith and Pocahontas
may have never actually been in love are
you new around here don't forget to give
this video a big Thumbs Up And subscribe
to the things for more great content
like this now on to the messed up real
story of Pocahontas the film
was it just us or was Pocahontas one of
your favorite Disney Princesses too she
was a total boss whereas most princesses
are kind of Meek and gentle and do
whatever their fathers tell them in the
film Pocahontas was her own person she
did what she wanted and she never took
no for an answer okay if you aren't
familiar with the film first of all what
have you been doing with your life but
we'll be kind and back up a little bit
so the Disney film centers around
Pocahontas who is the daughter of the
chief of the palatin tribe at the
beginning of the movie our favorite
heroine learns that her father wants to
marry her off to kokum who seems nice
and is super hot but Pocahontas just
doesn't love him during all of this time
the British settlers come to
Pocahontas's land John Smith one of the
settlers is less interested in the gold
that his crew came to find and more
interested about actually exploring the
new world while he is exploring he meets
and falls in love with Pocahontas but
their love affair is pretty doomed
because Jon tells his leader that there
is no no gold in the land and instead of
backing off the leader declares that
they will wipe out all of the natives
seems reasonable right in the midst of
all this secret romance and battling
Thomas one of John's friends ends up
taking kokom's life later John is taken
as captive but instead of letting him be
hurt Pocahontas throws herself in front
of Jon and begs her father to save him
and not to start a war Jon is spared but
does end up getting the gunshot wound
and has to travel back to England for
treatment but before they part
Pocahontas promises Jon that he will
always be in her heart so cute right
well it's all a bunch of Make-Believe
Pocahontas is the first Disney movie
that was created about a real life
person except Disney didn't actually
include many of the real details
the real story
here's what really happened apparently
Pocahontas's mother died giving birth to
her her birth name was actually
Metallica which means flower between two
streams and was probably given to her
because she was born between the rivers
of the mataponi and the pamanki after
her mother died Pocahontas's father was
really sad and Pocahontas became his
favorite child because she looked so
much like her mother she was raised by
her aunts and other women in their tribe
during that time it was customary for
the Paramount Chief to have other wives
so Pocahontas's dad had a few other
wives in other Villages so the family
wasn't just Pocahontas and her dad like
the movie made it seem here's where the
story starts to get creepy according to
her tribe history Pocahontas was only
about 10 years old when John Smith and
the colonists arrived in 1607. John
Smith was around 27 so if they did have
something going on it would have been
absolutely disgusting luckily they were
actually never married or even involved
with one another the children of
Pocahontas conscious tribe were all
watched very carefully and because she
was a princess of sorts she was probably
watched even more closely and provided
with cultural training that the other
children did not get on the other side
in the movie we saw John Smith as this
guest guy who saw all men as equal and
was both equally kind and hot in real
life the native people stayed away from
him because he was known to go into
people's Villages and put guns to their
heads and demand food and other supplies
in the winter John Smith met with the
powatin Warriors and ended up being
captured by the chief's brother luckily
for John the powhatans agreed with the
English on one thing they both feared
being attacked by the Spanish so they
formed an alliance after a while the
tribe began to like John and offered him
a role as a leader and gave him a better
area to live in after many years passed
John said that Pocahontas saved his life
during the four day process where he was
initiated into a leadership position
with the tribe but according to written
accounts from Pocahontas's tribe that
could have never happened this is for a
few reasons first the tribe wouldn't
have been trying to hurt him if he was
receiving such a big honor second
children weren't allowed in any of the
ritual ceremonies so Pocahontas wouldn't
have been allowed to be in attendance so
though the movie showed Pocahontas
selflessly throwing herself in front of
John Smith that never happened in real
life Pocahontas also never actually
defied her dad to bring food to John
Smith and his crew in Jamestown why not
well because Jamestown was 12 miles from
where Pocahontas lived there's no way a
10 year old girl would have traveled
that far alone especially not a Chief's
daughter if she did somehow manage to
escape her father and her people to head
to Jamestown she would have had to cross
several bodies of water that would have
required using one of the 400 pound
canoes that her tribe had there was no
way she could have lifted one of those
canoes Into the Water by herself so
Pocahontas actually didn't have much at
all to do with John Smith when she was
15 or 16 she actually did marry Coco one
had a child with him and moved to his
village soon a colonist named Samuel
Argyle went to look for Pocahontas in
order to capture her he demanded that
the tribe give her up or suffer an
attack she was forced to leave her child
in the village and go with Samuel though
she went as she was told kokom was still
attacked after she left later Pocahontas
married Englishman John Ralph and
converted to Christianity some say that
she married him for love but she was
never allowed to see her family again so
it doesn't sound like the relationship
was very mutually beneficial John Ralph
is mentioned in the second Pocahontas
film and she does go on to marry him in
the movie but Disney conveniently leaves
out the kidnapping and how the two ended
up meeting probably because no one would
be able to sleep through the night after
hearing the real story Rapunzel is
probably one of the best Disney
Princesses ever but will you like her as
much once you know what really happened
to her stay tuned until the end to know
how her fairy tale ended if you love
Disney princesses as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you the disturbing real story
behind Disney's Tangled the beginning
once upon a time there was a man and a
woman who always wished to have a child
but every attempt failed then one day
the woman was looking through the window
and saw a garden filled with the most
beautiful herbs and flowers it belonged
to a witch with great power who was
feared by everyone so no one dared to
enter there but when the woman saw some
Rapunzel in the garden she wanted them
so badly that she became miserably ill
this was when she asked her husband to
get some Rapunzel from the garden or she
would die and he loved her so much that
he decided to do it no matter the cost
this is why he climbed over the high
Hall in the sorceress's garden to steal
the Rapunzel his wife ate it and asked
for more but the second time he went
into the garden the man got caught by
the witch this is why she asked for the
first child that his wife would bring to
the world and she would take care of it
like a mother the man agreed and this is
how the little Rapunzel was adopted by
the witch but instead of treating her
like her own child she locked her in a
tower with only a little window when she
was 12 years old whenever she wanted to
see her she just had to ask Rapunzel to
let down her hair and she climbed up the
prince Rapunzel was feeling really
lonely in her tower that was until a
prince was riding through the forest he
heard the beautiful voice of the young
woman who was singing in her Tower
unfortunately he couldn't find any way
to climb up the tower he came back
another day and saw the witch climbing
up her hair this is why he had the idea
to pretend that he was the witch asked
Rapunzel to let down her hair and
climbed up the young woman had never
seen a man before and she was terrified
but then he began talking to her in a
friendly Manner and she lost her fear he
immediately asked her if she would take
him as her husband and she immediately
said yes however she didn't know how to
get down this is why she asked him to
bring a strand of silk every time he
would come to the tower this way she
would be able to weave a ladder and she
would climb down when it would be
finished then he would have the chance
to take her on his horse this is why
they made sure that they would be able
to see each other every evening to make
sure that the witch wouldn't see him
during the day however their fairy tale
ended when the young Rapunzel made one
big mistake the pregnancy in the latest
version of the story Rapunzel was simply
dumb enough to ask a really stupid
question out of nowhere she asked the
witch why it was more difficult to pull
her up compared to the young prince who
will be arriving any moment now but
another version of the story is a little
less appropriate for children when you
know that the prince didn't mind
climbing up Rapunzel's hair every night
you probably guessed that his intention
was not only to bring her a strand of
silk after all it would have been easier
to Simply bring a ladder and the couple
would have been able to run away
together but the prince was really
interested in being in her room every
night and you know what this can lead to
the young woman innocently asked the
witch why her waistband was getting
bigger this is when the witch understood
that the young Rapunzel was pregnant the
couple had been having fun before
marriage and the prince never told her
that she could get pregnant from this
this was when the witch understood that
she had been seeing a man during all
this time even though she had tried to
remove her from the world then the witch
decided to punish her and this is not
something that any kid would like to see
the tragedy when she found out that
Rapunzel had been betraying her during
all this time she decided to cut off her
hair then she took the pregnant young
woman Into the Wilderness where she saw
suffered greatly on the same day the
witch decided to stay in the tower and
tied the cut off hair to the hook at the
top of the tower by the way that means
that Rapunzel would have been able to
escape on her own if she cut her hair
but she also told the witch about her
prince so she was probably not that
smart after spending so many years alone
in a tower anyway the prince asked
Rapunzel to let down her hair and this
was when the witch let down the cutoff
hair to trick him the prince climbed up
the tower and this was when he found the
witch who was waiting for him she told
him you have come for your mistress
darling but that beautiful bird is no
longer sitting in her nest nor is she
singing anymore the cat got her and will
scratch your eyes out as well you have
lost Rapunzel you will never see her
again the prince was overcome with grief
and he threw himself from the tower he
survived but fell into Thorns that poked
out his eyes the end that couldn't be a
fairy tale without a happy ending but
unfortunately it wasn't as good as it
seems the prince had become blind and he
wandered around in the forest eating
nothing but grass and Roots but the most
terrible thing was probably that he lost
the love of his life that was until he
finally found the place where Rapunzel
has been living with the twins she had
given birth to that means that she had
given birth alone in the wilderness even
though she didn't even know what
pregnancy was the prince heard a voice
that sounded familiar he approached it
and this is when Rapunzel finally
recognized him the young woman then
threw her arms around his neck crying
two of her tears fell into his eyes and
the prince wasn't blind anymore this was
when he was able to lead her into his
kingdom where he and his new family were
received with joy in another version of
the story Rapunzel had to live alone in
the desert which makes things worse but
both stories had the same happy ending
the young couple then lived happily ever
after with her two kids which story do
you prefer the original tale or the
Disney movie don't be shy to answer in
the comments section down below we love
to hear what you think once upon a time
our favorite Disney Princesses belong to
very different fairy tales we're about
to pull their surprising stories out
from under the rug did you know that
beast and Belle's love story was
actually based on a real life couple
keep watching to get the full story take
it with you
with you so you'll always have a way to
look back
Princess Rapunzel Rapunzel's story dates
back to the 17th century but the folk
tale is centuries older than that it all
started when Rapunzel's mother was
pregnant with her and she began having
cravings for an herb that her daughter
would later be named after Rapunzel's
father was caught stealing the plant
from a witch's garden and agreed to give
up his unborn child as Penance
consequently Rapunzel was locked up and
raised in a doorless tower one day a
prince stumbled across the tower and
climbed up unannounced he fell in love
with Rapunzel who soon fell pregnant
when her pregnancy became obvious the
witch abandoned her in the desert one
night the prince returned to the tower
to find an ugly witch instead of his
beautiful bride-to-be you want me to be
the bad guy
fine now I'm the bad guy he flung
himself from the tower in disgust
blinding himself in the process and if
that wasn't bad enough he went on to
roam the desert for seven years before
crossing paths with Rapunzel again who
had given birth to a set of 20 wins all
on her own Rapunzel's tears of joy cured
the prince's blindness and they returned
to his kingdom to live happily ever
after chief Moana
unlike Rapunzel Moana was purely
invented by Disney the story of demigod
Maui on the other hand is a very popular
one among specific Islanders Disney
chose to simplify his backstory by
making him an orphan
he took one look and
decided
they did not want me but now he
originally came from the big and complex
family the Maui myths are a part of Maui
mythology which follows the Maui
brothers and their many accomplishments
Disney paid homage to the Maui
Polynesian myths by adding some of the
Gods victories into his lyrics Maui was
known for using his Fish Hook to pull up
Islands from the Pacific Ocean which is
said to have formed the Polynesian
Islands although moana's story starts
and ends with Disney Maui's is centuries
old Princess Anna and Queen Elsa the
Frozen sisters story is Loosely based on
the Hans Christian Anderson's fairy tale
The Snow Queen
yourself for me however they're far from
being sisters in their original Tales
the story's protagonists are Gerda and
Kai who are two childhood friends when
Kai gets kidnapped by the Snow Queen
Gerda goes on a terrifying and
challenging quest in hopes of bringing
him back home problem is the snow
Queen's kiss has frozen Kai's heart
wiped his memory and turned him into a
devoted follower Gerda risks her life to
save her friend showing true love in the
process gerda's Love Is Enough To Save
Kai in the end yeah we can totally see
where Disney Drew their inspiration from
Princess Mulan unlike the other Disney
Princesses Mulan is believed to have
been a real life person who lived during
the northern and southern dynasties Hua
mulan's story was passed down from
generation to generation through the
ballad of Mulan this old ballad told
Tales of mulan's bravery and victory
mulan's story has been retold throughout
Chinese history there have been many
adaptations and plays before dinner
honor but the original story is very
different than the Disney movie we all
know and love when Mulan finds out that
the men in her family must defend China
she volunteers to take her father's
place
watch over Mulan her parents give her
their blessing and Mulan leaves to fight
for 12 whole years unlike Disney's Mulan
Hua Milan already knew how to fight and
was gifted in martial arts sword
fighting and archery it said that no one
realized she was a woman until the war
was over that's when her fellow soldiers
first saw her wearing traditional female
Chinese clothing Princess Ariel Disney's
The Little Mermaid and Hans Christian
Anderson's 19th century fairy tale by
the same name have a lot in common well
except for a happy ending of course both
their stories start with young gorgeous
mermaids who visit the surface they both
saved the prince from drowning and fall
in love with him
[Music]
run away with you
this is also
sudden wanting nothing more than to
marry their love the mermaids visit a
sea witch to strike a deal and here's
where their stories start to differ in
Ariel's original story she gives the sea
witch her voice and tongue in exchange
for human legs but there's a catch
walking on her new legs is agonizing if
Ariel succeeds in getting the prince to
marry her she'll be granted a human soul
but if she fails her heart will break
and she'll dissolve into Sea Foam
unfortunately for The Little Mermaid the
prince marries a neighboring princess
who he believes to have saved him from
the Shipwreck the mermaid sisters strike
a deal with a sea witch to save her life
if the mermaid succeeds in murdering the
prince with a special knife and placing
a drop of blood on her feet she will
live understandably The Little Mermaid
is unable to carry out this task and
dissolves into Sea Foam Princess Belle
we weren't kidding around when we said
that Bell and Beast love story was the
real deal Disney's The Beauty and the
Beast was inspired by real life events
that occurred in France during the 16th
century
I want to do something for her the fairy
tale was written by French author
Gabrielle Suzanne barbot David
Villanueva she Drew inspiration from
Petrus gonzalves and his bride-to-be
Catherine's very peculiar romance Petra
suffered from a condition called
hypertrichosis which caused him to grow
thick hair all over his body and face it
made him look like a total beast and he
was treated as such by the townsfolk
Catherine and Petrus got married and had
seven children and managed to live out
their version of a happily ever after so
there you guys have it the real stories
behind our favorite Disney Princess
movies A Tale As Old As Time sounds
romantic but if it hadn't been changed
to the Disney movie we know and love
there's a good chance you might not be
as much of a Beauty and the Beast fan
keep watching to find out how Belle was
meant to ease the fear of an arranged
marriage if you are new here make sure
to subscribe to the things and give our
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out the disturbing real story behind
Beauty and the Beast
the recent Beauty and the Beast
live-action movie features one of
Hollywood's most beloved feminists Emma
Watson it's difficult not to look for
elements of equality in a movie that
continues to be such a big part of our
childhoods however like any narrative
it's important to examine where the
story comes from if anything unveiling
the story's darker past might even add
to our current appreciation of the film
and the corresponding adjustments and
tweaks the story has undergone
throughout its life not always so strong
and independent there are a lot of
misconceptions when it comes to our
interpretations of the Love Story
between Belle and the Beast for example
many fans perceive Val's ability to make
her own decisions as a sign of her
independence like when she courageously
sets out to save her father this is
impressive for a Disney princess as she
strives to defy the patriarchy that
tries to limit her usefulness to solely
her good looks some have gone as far as
viewing Belle as a feminist character
though this may be true for our
perspective in our current social
climate the tale or originated as part
of the oral storytelling tradition this
would have been decades prior to any
social or Civil Rights Movement making
it impossible for Belle to be a feminist
in her cultural and historical context
where does the story come from
looking at where the story of Beauty and
the Beast originated is very helpful in
understanding how far our interpretation
of bell has come a professor of folklore
and mythology Marie Tater explained how
this contextual change happened Tater
divulged in a grammar interview that the
story of Beauty and the Beast has
existed among communities for longer
than we can track the story we know and
love was first published in print by
French author Madame Gabrielle Suzanne
de vinov in this version Bell is a good
fairy and the descendant of a king this
tale was based on the real story of
Petrus gonzalves and his bride Catherine
Tetris was afflicted by a condition
called hypertrichnosis which caused
excessive hair growth all over his body
he was initially adopted by the French
royal family for their Amusement Petrus
would go on to marry Catherine and they
became a celebrity couple so using them
as inspiration for a printed version of
the existing oral tell makes sense after
all people want to read about things
they have experience with however it was
a friend author Jean-Marie Le Prince de
Beaumont who wrote a second print
version of the fairy tale beaumont's
version was meant to serve as a lesson
for girls ranging from ages as young as
5 to 13. her goal was not to empower
young women and Inspire them to make
their own decisions quite the opposite
Beauty and the Beast was meant to prove
to Young 18th century readers that
arranged marriages aren't as bad as they
may seem for a girl a potential husband
who was older and much hairier would not
be so unlike the Beast Belle eventually
Falls for by the time it was Rewritten
by Beaumont Belle was no longer royalty
but instead the daughter of an inventor
the purpose of this was to ensure that
the story would be relatable to a French
population that was becoming
increasingly frustrated by the growth of
an aristocratic class the story was then
interpreted into the version we know
best by English author named Andrew Lang
this version was the most popular as it
was translated into several languages
and served as the inspiration for movies
and songs
the Disney version
finally in the most recent live-action
film director Bill Condon added another
modification in this version Bell is an
inventor who creates a washing machine
to provide her with more time for
reading the nature of the invention has
also been criticized as Reliant too
heavily on gender roles we can use this
as a true Testament of how far audiences
have come the Disney animated and
live-action narrative suggests that Bell
makes an independent decision to save
her father and sacrifices her own
freedom in exchange the Beast depicted
as angry and violent eventually succumbs
to Belle's intelligence and kindness and
they find a love that transcends
appearance this is not the case in the
original story instead Belle isn't to
live with the Beast who is more
attractive and offers her any luxury she
desires by the end of the story she
accepts her situation and falls in love
with the creature she's been destined to
marry this would not have been too
unlike young girls who were forced to
marry older men another theory presented
by Tater is that the bee serves as a
metaphor for fear itself following this
Logic the Beast is a representation of
Belle's fears once she confronts these
fears and feels at peace with them she
is able to see the Beast for who he is
as her judgment is no longer clouded by
her concerns essentially through the
scary image of the Beast the audience is
supposed to learn that the worst part of
being held captive against your will is
your fear once you move past that you
will see that life isn't as bad as it
seems Disney found a way to flip this on
its head making sure that the beast's
insecurities were the reason for his
harsh attitude towards the rest of
society that had exiled him the takeaway
on one hand Disney is advocating for a
feminist rendition of Beauty and the
Beast on the other hand we may continue
to find fault in the problematic power
dynamics that Prevail in all retellings
of the story nevertheless the movie
continues to bring up important
questions about what it means to be in a
healthy relationship as long as it's
properly contextualized for a young
audience presenting difficult and
uncomfortable narratives from an
outdated literary tradition might cause
us to continue to question the gender
roles we still take for granted
according to Disney Belle's compassion
and intelligence allows beasts to show
himself for who he is instead of Belle
having to accept her situation she helps
the Beast confront his own issues and
become a better version of himself
somehow Disney has successfully turned a
story about female oppression and
arranged marriages into an inspiring
lesson about seeing others for who they
truly are the Disney movie Aladdin is
full of colorful and funny characters
singing catchy songs as they fly around
on a Magic Carpet it's a high-flying
tale of romance mad magic and Adventure
but the real story is actually pretty
messed up new here subscribe to the
things channel to be the first to see
our newest videos and click the like
button if you enjoyed this video now
here is the messed up real story of
Aladdin
the original author before we dive into
the actual story of Aladdin which is
part of a Saga called Arabian nights or
1001 Nights we have to talk about the
woman who created the stories according
to the Atlantic Arabian Knights is a set
of folk tales that was passed down
orally until the 9th century and then
compiled into a bunch of different
written versions and translations each
translator put their own spin on these
stories depending on their perspective
and the times they were living in but
the truth about the original creation on
these stories is pretty messed up so a
long time ago a psycho-persian king had
a crazy reputation for slaying his new
Brides after their wedding night and
finding a new wife in the morning there
was a clever chick by the name of
shaharazad who knew about the king's
reputation she was forced to marry this
deranged lunatic but she had a little
trick up her sleeve every night before
he went to sleep she would tell the king
a story and end it with a cliffhanger to
keep him in suspense this kept the king
hooked while ensuring she would live
another night because he wanted to find
out how the story ended this girl
basically invented the Cliffhanger in
order to save her own skin the result
was a series of folktales that have been
handed down over the years translated
into a bunch of different languages and
eventually became a Disney movie that we
all loved shaharazad probably would have
loved Robin Williams portrayal of the
genie a common theme in these stories is
the cleverness of women to overcome
oppression acclaims Lebanese author
Hanan al-shek who retold stories of
Arabian Nights had a very interesting
take on this series she said she
believes shaharazad's power over the
king does not stop with her ability to
keep herself Alive by entertaining him
ultimately she exerts far more power
over him than that the author says each
story was a plea for reason and mercy
through all these stories she is trying
to influence the king and maybe even
brainwash him these stories Hanan
al-shek believes slowly taught the king
to give up his evil Tendencies and
hatred of women in her stories
shaharazad mirrors her own predicament
all of her characters are pleading for
life in their own way she cleverly
disguised these stories making the
characters and topics slightly different
but the author pointed out that the main
point of these stories is that you cease
to be a human being if you steep
yourself in brutality and evil it's
important to note that the story of
Aladdin was not added to the collection
of Arabian nights until much later by a
French translator named Antoine's
galland still the story of Aladdin
suddenly becomes much more intriguing
when you think about a woman making it
up on the spot for a Mad King in order
to save her own life
the origin
many people know that Aladdin was
originally set in China because of the
storyteller's Persian Roots Hollywood
set the story in the Middle East with
films like the thief of Baghdad from
1924 and 1940. and of course Disney's
Aladdin but actually the character
Aladdin was Chinese and originally he
wasn't a crafty orphan either the first
version depicted him as a lazy dude who
lived at home with his mom that's far
less appealing right no wonder they
changed the part the Disney film was
originally to be set in Baghdad but the
U.S was attacking Baghdad in the first
Gulf War while the film was in
production so Disney decided to change
the setting to the fictional city of
Agrabah probably a good idea on their
part
racism
there are a lot of racial stereotypes in
Disney's animated version of Aladdin but
did you know that they actually had to
change the lyrics to the opening song
because it was considered super racist
Arab American activists protested and
caused Disney to change the lyrics after
the film had already been released which
is unprecedented we'll get to those
lyrics in a minute the song wasn't the
only thing the Arab Community had a
problem with according to Don bustany
the president of the Los Angeles chapter
of the American Arab anti-discrimination
committee there Still Remains The Very
sleazy burlesque character in The
prologue and the scene where a merchant
is going to cut off the hands of
Princess Jasmine because she took an
apple from his stand to give to a hungry
child bustany said what's even worse is
that the supporting characters are all
depicted as nasty mean people while the
Aladdin character Jasmine and her father
speak with no accent standard
Americanized English all the bad guys
speak in Foreign Accents the lesson is
that anyone with a foreign accent is bad
he called it horrendous racism now back
to those song lyrics part of the
original lyrics in the opening number of
Aladdin saying about a far away place
where the camels roam where they cut off
your ear if they don't like your face
then the lyrics say it's barbaric but
hey it's home yikes that's pretty dicey
for a Disney cartoon after angry
protests and criticism from the Arab
Community Disney changed the lyrics to
have the characters sing about a Faraway
place where it's flat and immense and
the heat is intense they left the part
where they say it's barbaric Disney made
the change after several meetings with
the Arab American anti-discrimination
Committee Disney distribution President
Dick cook said it was something they did
because they wanted to do it he said in
no way would they ever do anything that
would be insensitive to anyone so on
reflection they changed it still the
Arab American anti-discrimination
Committee was not completely happy with
the change and requested to have the
word barbaric removed from the song as
well but Disney refused saying that the
word barbaric referred to the land and
the Heat and not to the people what do
you think should they have changed the
word barbaric it appears we still have a
long way to go with learning how to be
kind inclusive and tolerant but as
Aladdin has taught us it's never too
late to apologize and make things right
let's hope Disney has learned from this
and applies it to the Remake they have
an opportunity to create a film from a
story that was born from horrible
oppression and perhaps turn it into a
Triumph of the human Spirit an inclusive
celebration of culture and a few more
catchy tunes that have us tapping our
toes rather than shaking our heads we
all love The Lion King but do you know
that it was actually based on a real
story and it wasn't just one stay tuned
to hear more about the strange biblical
story that was one of the Lion King's
main Inspirations if you're new here
make sure to subscribe to the things and
give our video a big thumbs up now let's
check out the disturbing real story
behind The Lion King
Hamlet
did you know that the Lion King was
actually a loose adaptation of
Shakespeare's Hamlet the story share a
lot of similarities and if you take away
the adorable animals it's actually
pretty disturbing it's hard to believe
such a heartwarming Disney movie could
share the same story as one of
Shakespeare's longest plays to make
things worse the story of Hamlet was
actually based on a true story so keep
that in mind when you watch The Lion
King stay tuned to hear a summary of
Hamlet and some of the similarities this
disturbing story shared with one of our
favorite Disney movies we'll also show
you another weird story that was an
inspiration for a lot of Lion King
moments the real story Hamlet is all
about the prince of Denmark the
depressed and bitter son of the late
King Hamlet just like Simba the prince
of Denmark was an only child without any
other siblings so all focus is on him
throughout the play Hamlet's Story
begins when we get to meet his uncle
Claudius who has already become a king
it's implied that there's a chance this
was done by intentionally ending his
brother's life sounds familiar earlier
yes but we bet it's also pretty
disturbing when there's actual people
involved right but let's continue Hamlet
also has a friend from college called
Horatio who helps him on several
occasions throughout the story he also
ends up falling out with two University
friends after it's revealed they're just
spies who are actually working for
Claudius things get even more
complicated in the early stages of the
story Claudius marries Hamlet's mother
and becomes his own enemy stepfather
when Hamlet hears the details of his
father's murder from a ghost who claims
to be his father's Spirit he decides to
take revenge to make things even worse
Claudius is not the only person young
Hamlet has to worry about when his
father was still alive he won the battle
for a disputed piece of land and ended
up killing king Ford and Bros the King's
son now also wants to avenge the death
and the land that once was owned by his
father the story of Hamlet takes an even
darker turn in the third act when
Hamlet's Revenge plan to kill Claudius
goes wrong instead he ends up ending the
life of of Polonius who was revealed to
be claudius's spy to make things even
more Twisted Polonius has a daughter
Ophelia who's madly in love with Hamlet
but she also ends up not surviving the
play polonius's son is desperate to
avenge his father's accidental death and
ultimately achieve this in the Final Act
of this dark story the long story is
full of mysteries and dark twists that
are full of symbolism and disturbing
imagery in fact one of the most frequent
symbols refers to flowers as every
flower mentioned in the story has a
completely different meaning that
defines the character it's intended for
but it seems like Hamlet is also full of
various characters dying because of
Revenge or accident which seems to also
be one of the main themes in the play so
now you know the brief summary of what
Hamlet's all about let's talk about the
actual similarities to The Lion King
similarities
as we mentioned before both Hamlet and
Simba were princes without any brothers
or sisters they both also feature a
crazy uncle that's jealous of their
father's success and wants to take the
crown away from them both characters
also have a single love interest of
course both of their fathers are also
murdered while King Hamlet's death isn't
quite clear as the only details of the
ACT come from a ghost we all know far
too well what happened to King Mufasa
another interesting detail is that both
fathers reappear as ghosts Mufasa
appears to Simba in The Stars and King
Hamlet's an actual ghost both characters
are also sent to Exile Simba grows up
with Timon and Pumbaa while Hamlet
travels to England and even survives an
attack by Pirates both stories are also
heavily marked by the tone of Revenge
although that might be less obvious in
The Lion King but Simba does take
revenge and we all know hyenas end up
taking care of Scar Claudius on the
other hand is killed with a sword and
poisoned wine both stories also have a
highlighted internal struggle that
drives the main characters to their
ultimate acts in The Lion King we see
Simba struggle with the decision to
become a king as he's too ashamed of his
past and childhood mistakes on the other
hand Hamlet has to decide whether or not
he wants to take Revenge by ending
another person's life
Joseph
but it's not just Hamlet The Lion King
also shares a few similarities with the
biblical story of Joseph and the writers
admitted they took inspiration from the
old testament's Book of Genesis the
story focuses on Joseph the
over-ambitious son of Jacob Jacob had 10
other children who were all aware that
Joseph was the favorite they wanted
revenge and sold Joseph to slave Traders
while telling their father that his son
was killed by wild animals after a long
journey with plenty of moments in
between Joseph eventually ends up in a
position of power and allows him to
punish his brothers and becomes reunited
with his father he also has the power
over the land and makes sure his family
is well off for the rest of their time
while the story of Hamlet is definitely
the one that shares more characteristics
and similarities to the one and only
Lion King the Disney movie was actually
inspired by plenty of biblical stories
like this one and to be completely
honest with you they're all kind of
disturbing when you realize these are
human characters and not adorable
animals and lions that are just learning
how to Roar Plus without a funky musical
number the whole situation is really
dark especially for a story that's meant
to be for kids it's hard to believe
these creepy stories were actually the
base for one of Disney's most iconic
movies isn't it we all watched the
Disney movie The Little Mermaids but
only a few of us know what really
happened to Ariel in the original tale
and this is not a fairy tale story for
kids make sure you watch this video
Until the End to know if the mermaid
lives happily ever after or not if you
love The Little Mermaid as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you the messed up origins of
The Little Mermaid here's what Hans
Christian Anderson wrote in 1836 in a
tale called The Little Mermaid once
again The Little Mermaid was one of the
King's Daughters and the most beautiful
of them but this time everyone including
her sisters was fascinated by the human
world and what she loved more was a
Marvel Statue of a handsome man her
grandmother told her everything about
the human world and and unlike Scuttle
she was actually really wise she told
The Little Mermaid about the day when
she was going to turn 15 and have the
right to rise up out of the sea sit on
the rocks in the Moonlight and see what
is happening on the land The Little
Mermaid who was the youngest daughter in
her family waited several years for that
day her sisters kept talking about what
they saw and the youngest couldn't wait
for the day when she was going to see it
too at first they were amazed but after
visiting this place too often they
became indifferent and didn't care
anymore when the moment she had been
waiting for finally came The Little
Mermaid Rose to the surface of the sea
this is when she saw a boat came closer
to it and noticed a really handsome
prince it was love at first sight but
then a storm came her man fell in the
water and she had to save him as she lay
on the shore she kissed his forehead and
admired the man who looked just like the
marble statue that she used to love she
waited until someone came to help him
and then laugh The Little Mermaid
couldn't forget this man and she spent
many nights in the water near his Palace
to watch The Young Prince unlike her
sisters she kept loving this new world
more every time she learned more about
him every day and even heard the
fishermen talking about how great he was
The Little Mermaid wished that she could
be part of his world however she
realized that they were actually really
different in this tale humans could die
while mermaids could live up to 300
years but humans also had a soul that
lives forever while sea creatures just
cease to exist when they died this was
one of the main reasons why the Little
Mermaid wanted to become a real woman
her grandmother tried to convince her
that mermaids lived to be much happier
and much better than humans but the
young girl didn't mind she could die for
her prince if it meant being happy as
stars in the sky forever but her
grandmother told her that the only way
she could have an immortal Soul was if
the man fell in love with her if they
ever got married his soul would Glide in
her body and they would be United this
is why while everyone was at the ball
she decided that she would do anything
it would take to meet her prince her
grandmother told her that a fishtail was
beautiful under the sea but looked
disgusting on Earth and this is why she
had to find a way to have legs she went
to see the Sorceress and even the sea
witch said that she was stupid but there
was something she could do for her The
Little Mermaid could drink a drought
that would make her tail disappear and
turn into legs that would make her the
prettiest little human being they ever
saw but this transformation will feel as
if a sword was passing through her and
every step she takes would feel like she
was treading upon sharp knives if she
could bear with this the Sorceress would
help her and the Little Mermaid was so
desperate that she said yes the sea
witch had to warn her that once she
became human she will never see the ones
that she loves ever again and only
become foam on the crest of the Waves it
wasn't enough to stop the young girl but
then the Sorceress said that she had to
pay the prince in exchange for a pair of
legs she had to give away her voice the
mermaid said yes one last time and the
Sorceress cut off her tongue before
preparing the drought The Little Mermaid
didn't even take the time to say goodbye
to those she loved as she felt too dumb
after making that choice when she rose
up through the dark blue Waters to go on
the shore and drink the magic drought
she felt like a two-edged sword went
through her delicate body and fell just
like she was dead as she discovered from
the sharp pain a prince Stood Beside her
he took her to his Palace but every step
she took felt as if treading upon the
points of needles or sharp knives but
she mostly felt dumb as she couldn't
speak when this handsome man tried to
talk to her she was jealous when she
heard a beautiful slave singing her
voice was so beautiful that the prince
was only looking at her but the Little
Mermaid stole the show when she finally
had the chance to dance with the prince
even though though she was suffering
during all this time she spent more and
more time with her lover kissing and
cuddling but she kept smiling while she
couldn't stop thinking about the pain as
the day passed she was more in love with
the prince but he loved the silent girl
only as he would love a child and not as
his future wife he even called her his
dumb child the prince needed to find a
beautiful princess to marry but he only
had one on his mind he kept thinking
about the woman who saved his life and
the Little Mermaid couldn't tell him
that it was her the prince finally met a
woman who was so beautiful that he
thought that she was the one who saved
him and told the little mermaid that he
was finally happy but the young girl was
heartbroken and it hurt more than her
legs his wedding was going to bring her
to death she held up the bride's train
and danced all night no matter how
painful that was as it was the last
night that she would spend with her
friends as she looked at the Sea The
Little Mermaid saw her sister they had
heard about this tragedy and gave their
hair to the witch in exchange for a
knife if the young girl plunged it in
the heart of the prince before the sun
rises she would become a mermaid again
and have the chance to be with her
family again but she couldn't do it The
Little Mermaid threw away the knife and
threw herself into the sea where her
body dissolved into foam but she didn't
die she became one of the daughters of
the air by her good deeds she had earned
an immortal Soul she would be flying
around the world in the air until after
300 years she should float into the
kingdom of heaven and this is how the
Little Mermaid had the chance to live
her happily ever after in peace away
from pain which Fairy Tales story do you
prefer don't be shy to answer in the
comment section down below